auf dem truppenübungsplatz allentsteig
hand von 15 26
juni 2015 die übung handwerk 15 startet
unter dem kommando der vierten partie
brigade übten 1200 soldaten und
soldatinnen den schutz von räumen
verkehrswegen und objekten
geübt wurde das zusammenwirken von
panzern und räder fahrzeugen und
soldaten der abc abwehr gruppe der jäger
gruppe der pionier truppe und der
aufklärung
der schwerpunkt des heutigen tages
bestand in der erkennung von gelände und
den abtransport von gefangenen
wir haben heute gefangenen übernommen
und nach einer kurzen durchsuchung in
ein gefangenenlager abtransportiert
wir in diesem bereich wurde ein
kontrollpunkt errichtet um den
ungehinderten zutritt von demonstranten
zum schutz objekt welches durch die
kaderpräsenzeinheiten des jägerbataillon
geschützt wird zu verhindern ich bin zum
beispiel sichere schütze eingesetzt beim
vorgehen von der kompanie oder als
wunderwaffen schütze bei ca
mein eindruck ist gut war wir können
unser sachen machen was man in straße
zum beispiel mitmachen können vom
gelände her
bei dieser übung ist schwergewicht auf
der gefechte schutz kling und das ist
eigentlich nicht ist normal einzig vom
rovers nach rechts schießen mit der
baunummer mit die maschinengewehre
sondern wir sind einfach nur die weichen
ziele spricht infanteristen denen schutz
geben dass sie in der wirtschaft eine
kindern wo super sie für kräfte einer
unwesen treiben die meiste zeit war ich
mit luke gedicht das bedeutet natürlich
sehr über die trauer spiegeln aus im
gegensatz zum auto und daher muss ich
mir von panzergranaten führen lassen rät
schütz und leopard und von der
handwerker mit dass man sehr gut
gefallen hat weil es eigentlich nichts
alltägliches ist was man so im leben
macht und der rechtsschütze ist der was
die partie kann ohne für beziehungsweise
dem grün schwenkt und braucht einen
guten einblick ins gelände weil der
einzige film der was das gelände
überwachen kann
und wenn er feind oder objekte kommen
dann muss natürlich dementsprechend
behandelt beziehungsweise gekämpft
werden
von a wie zb company rico zurück und so
aufgebaut dass man am panzer die
kontaminieren der vortrieb verstrickung
es ist jedermanns sache
am vorhaben wieder angst vor der masken
der schutzanzug diese damen und der sohn
schließt machen sie seit darwin rom gut
da bleibt man immer mal wieder außer
kommt aber so an sich ist ja ganz gut so
der hand weg 15 üben wir um fehler zu
erkennen und dementsprechend besser zu
werden
ich halte überhaupt nichts davon dass
wir täglich nach jeder übungsphase
zusammenkommen uns gegenseitig auf die
schulter klopfen und sagen uns betreuern
wie gut wir schon sind da ganz im
gegenteil gerade die standardsituationen
die wir hier regelmäßig durchführen
bieten die einmalige gelegenheit mit
führungs simulationen echtzeit
auswertung jeden einzelnen fehler zu
finden zu analysieren und
dementsprechend zu korrigieren
das ist natürlich gerade für uns
kommandanten teilweise sehr
schmerzhafter prozess der selbstkritik
aber nichtsdestotrotz bin ich davon
überzeugt der einzig richtig sinnvoll
und zweckmäßig weg uns fit zu machen für
derzeitigen zukünftige aufträge im in
und ausland
unter diesem gesichtspunkt bin ich
durchaus mit dem übungsverlauf der 115
zufrieden